you
You
Hi everyone and welcome to the table
My name is Karen and we're so glad that you're here tonight this Sunday evening
We are live and I want to say just a really special shout out to my mom who is tuning in right now
Hi, mom. I love you. Happy Mother's Day as others are joining us online
I want to share a couple of announcements and please do start commenting down below. Let us know you're here
We want to be able to welcome you personally, so just let us know who you are where you're watching from
So first announcement, we've been
highlighting each of our meetups lately and meetups are our small groups at the table and this week I have the honor of
spotlighting our men's support group led by the amazing Daryl Adams and
They meet online every Tuesday night at 7 p.m. Via Google Meets
it's a safe place where guys can share about their lives and open and vulnerable ways and
Like Daryl says you don't even have to get up off the couch to join in and I'll add to that
You don't even have to live in the area to join in because all of our meetups are virtual you can
Join from wherever you are and Daryl would love to have you
So if you are interested in being part of that and checking it out, you can reach out to Daryl directly at Daryl
Daryl at the table TX org or you can comment below or reach out to the table directly and we'll make sure to put
You in touch with Daryl
Secondly tonight. We're having a very special panel discussion on stress anxiety
Depression and the church
obviously, this is a timely topic right now that touches all of us whether directly or indirectly and
The discussion will include some Q&A
So we would love to be able to include your questions that you have for our panelists
So if you think of a question between now and then that please feel free to note that in the comments below
Or you can text it to us at nine seven two
eight three seven seven
Seven one nine one and we'll make sure to put that in the comments, too. So you have it
I can't promise we'll be able to get to all of the questions, but we promise to do our best
And as I'm sure you are already well aware of today is Mother's Day
This can be a day of great joy and celebration and also a day of deep sadness
grief and longing
It can be especially difficult for our LGBTQ friends, I
also can't help but think of
Ahmad Arbery's mom
Wanda as she grieves the murder of her son and the cover-up that went with it and the injustice
I just can't imagine what she's going through right now. So
just as a church, we want to make sure we're lifting her and the rest of Ahmad's family up in prayer and
It's just a good reminder you guys. Let's not just let this be a hashtag that passes over in a week
Let's learn and lean in and listen
and and learn how to be
Not just good people but actively anti-racist. It's time. So I hope as a church will will commit to that
So wherever you find yourself today
We see you we acknowledge your experience and we love you
This is a reading by Amy Young
called the wide spectrum of mothering
To those who gave birth this year to their first child
We celebrate with you
To those who lost a child this year
We mourn with you
To those who are in the trenches with little ones every day and where the badge of food stains we appreciate you
To those who experienced loss through miscarriage
Failed adoptions or running away
We mourn with you
To those who walked the hard path of infertility
Fraught with pokes, prods, tears, and disappointment
We walk with you
Forgive us when we say foolish things
We don't mean to make this harder than it is
To those who are foster moms, mentor moms, and spiritual moms. We need you
To those who have warm and close relationships with your children. We celebrate with you
To those who have disappointment, heartache, and distance with your children. We sit with you
To those who have lost their mothers. We grieve with you
To those who experienced abuse at the hands of your own mother
We acknowledge your experience
To those who lived through driving tests, medical tests, and a heart attack
To those who lived through driving tests, medical tests, and overall testing of motherhood
We are better for having you in our midst
To those who have aborted children, we remember them and you on this day
To those who are single and long to be married and mothering your own children
We mourn that life has not turned out the way you longed for it to be
To those who step parent, we walk with you on these complex paths
To those who envisioned lavishing love on grandchildren
Yet that dream is not to be
We grieve with you
To those who will have emptier nests in the coming year. We grieve and rejoice with you
To those who place children up for adoption
We
Commend you for your selflessness
And remember how you hold that child in your heart
And to those who are pregnant with new life both expected and surprising we anticipate with you
This Mother's Day
We walk with you
Mothering is not for the faint of heart and we have real warriors in our midst. We remember you
You
Come on crowd
Come on, greedy
Come on
Come on wealthy come receive it to the table come today
Come on broken
Come on meaty
Come on pouring
Come on slaves
Come on rulers
Come be seated
Come all sinners
Come all saints
Come to the table
From near and far
Come from the shadows
Come out of the dark
There's room at the table
We saved you out of state
Come to the banquet
Come join in the feast
Every race
Every nation
Come all rebels
Come all gays
From the fringes come to jesus
To the table
There's no
Let down your guard you're never a stranger
Just come as you are
Come be whole
Come be loved
Come
Come now
Come be whole
Come
Come be loved
Come accepted
Come now
Come
Be whole
Come be loved
Come accepted
Come now
Come
Prepare the table
We're ready to feast
The party is waiting
There's more still to feed
The harvest is ready
Go fill every seat
Go live out the mission
As a kingdom of priest
Lord
Even when your path takes me through the valley of deepest darkness
Fear will never conquer me for you already have
You remain close to me and lead me through it all the way
Your authority is my strength and my peace
I will not let you down
Your authority is my strength and my peace the comfort of your love takes away my fear
I'll never be lonely for you are near
You are life
You are love
You bring light
To the dark
Darkness
You give hope
You restore
Every heart
That is broken
And great
Are you
Lord
It's your will
In our
Love
So we pour out
Our faith
We pour out our faith
It's your will
In our love
So we pour out
Our faith
To you only
You are life
You are love
You bring light
To the dark
Darkness
You give hope
You restore
Every heart
That is broken
And great
Are you
Lord
It's your will
In our
Love
So we pour out
Our faith
We pour out our faith
It's your will
In our love
So we pour out
Our faith
To you only
Your will
In our love
So we pour out
Our faith
We pour out our faith
In our love
So we pour out
Our faith
To you only
And all the earth
Will shout
Your praise
Our hearts will cry
These bones will say
Great
Are
You
Lord
And all the earth
Will shout
Your praise
Our hearts will cry
These bones will say
Great
Are
You
Lord
And all the earth
Will shout
Your praise
Our hearts will cry
These bones will say
Great
Are
You
Lord
And all the earth
Will shout
Your praise
Our hearts will cry
These bones will say
Great
Are
You
Lord
It's your will
In our love
So we pour out
Our praise
We pour out our praise
It's your will
In our love
So we pour out
Our praise to you only
It's your will
Great
Are
You
Lord
We pour out our praise
It's your will
Great
Are
You
Lord
It's your will
In our love
So we pour out
Our praise
To you only
God we thank you today for moms
And all the mothers
Mothers that are
Raising children
Mothers that have lost children
Mothers that want to be children
Mothers that want to be children in their hearts
Father we thank you
For this day to honor
All the ones that take care of
The little ones in our lives
Thank you for
Being able to hang out
Over the internet
And still stay connected
In your name
Amen
Amen amen
Y'all
Thank you thank you Josh and Joe for leading us
In worship and
To Karen
For such a beautiful
Just
Welcome and just
Wonderful in your sharing
Of that reading from Mother's Day
It was beautiful
So welcome to all of you as well
I'm so glad that you could be here
My name is Brett and Pastor here and
Yeah welcome to the table
All you long timers and all you
Newcomers and everyone kind of in between
Yeah welcome
So glad you could join us so like we
Had mentioned earlier like Karen mentioned
We are
Tonight is a little bit unique in that
Where I'm not going to like do a
You know a monologue a talk
Instead we're going to do kind of basically a panel
Discussion
Titled stress anxiety depression
In the church and you know
Obviously we're in a really
Challenging time right now
With the quarantine
And it's pushed many of us
Just into some really
Challenging places
Regarding our mental health and
So with that we've
Been kind of in a series titled tranquility
Cultivating calm in a crazy
World where we've been asking
Like how can we
Find this tranquility how can we cultivate
This how can we draw
On the resources and the wealth
And spiritual practices and
You know in the scriptures in the Christian tradition
To help connect
Us to the spirit of God and
In the midst of this time and
You know find some tranquility
So
We've been doing that for like eight weeks now
However like you know all things that
That's a journey that's a process that's not
A snap of your fingers and suddenly like
Oh god I engaged this eight week series
Problem solved
Of course not which means many
Of us were you know we continue
To wrestle and struggle with this
Now you add
On top of that the fact that kind of
Historically in the church there's been
Some stigma with like
Mental health issues
Almost this posture of
Maybe
Like at times almost a silence
You know like hey don't
Don't really bring that up at church
Or be
Almost just some condemnation
You know like you just don't
You just don't have faith or something
So
Kind of with that background in mind
The leadership team here at the table we thought
It might just be helpful if we drew together
Some different voices
To have a panel discussion tonight I think I've done
Far far and away
Enough talking the last eight weeks
On this so we wanted
Just yeah some other voices
And so these these folks they were chosen
For a variety of reasons I mean
A because we trust them
The leadership team here at the table
We trust them we think they're earnest seekers of truth
Also they have
Like history and some experience in the church
And even many of them
With either like depression or anxiety
And even their own
Personal lives so they can you know speak to that
Side of things
So yeah let me go ahead and
Introduce our panelists
Tonight
So the first is Karen Leyva
And I'll do
I'll do a short little intro and then they'll introduce
Themselves more thoroughly in just a second
So Karen Leyva
Aaron Brown
There's Karen and Aaron Brown
Maggie
Porter and Jacob Porter
Four
Amazing people
And thank you all so much for joining
Us so all right so there's like
A variety of reasons I think each panelist kind of has
You know their like unique perspective
And a thing to bring to this
Discussion
Karen is she's super sharp
And she she lives with a chronic
Illness so she's no
Stranger to you know pain
And mental stress
And things Aaron is with a
Pastor and a psychiatrist Maggie
Has dealt with bouts of
Anxiety and has done
Some really good work and learning to kind of work
Through that Jacob
Both he
He obviously he's we're not
I should say obviously so Jacob and Maggie
They're married so
He's you know in a relationship with someone
Who's who's struggling with these kinds
Of things and he has kind of his own
Long journey with
The church and I'll
Let him share a little bit about that if you'd like so he has
Sort of an insider outsider perspective
That I thought might be really
Helpful so
I'd like our panels to go ahead and share just a
Little bit about themselves I gave you like you know the
10 second version so y'all can
You know give us a few minutes on just
A little bit about like where you're from
Your connection to the table
Why this topic
Matters to you
So let's go ahead and start with Karen
If that's okay
Yes I
First of all English is not my
First language so be
Gentle and graceful
But I
Was born and raised in Guatemala in a
Very pride center family
And so I had that
Beautiful background to help me go through a lot
And then five years
Ago I was diagnosed with
Rheumatoid arthritis and it
Just changed my life
I had to go from
Being someone who was very
Sharp and who prided
Herself for
Being intelligent and
Having education and pursuing
These different degrees
To someone who would fall asleep
In front of the computer
Who couldn't pick up
A cup of coffee to my lips
And I just fell into
This very dark
Hole
Grieving who I used to be
There was just this profound
Loss
I am not going to lie to you and tell you that
Oh I lost all my chances for
Marathons because I was never that kind of
Person
I did feel like I lost
A lot of who I was
And things that I
Thought were my identity
And that became just one of those
Things that I couldn't get out of
I mean
It's so hard for people
Without chronic illnesses to understand
That the pain just envelops you
And that
When you are in that kind of pain
Days are
Very long
Seconds are amplified
When you are feeling them through pain
So
I had this view of
Tomorrow will be a good day
But at the same time I was so aware
Of the next 10 seconds
Of the next 30 seconds
Because I was in pain
So I think for me
That anxiety depression thing
Even though it did start
Before this it got amplified a lot
When I went through my diagnosis
Of a chronic illness
Yeah
Thank you Karen for sharing
And let me
Before we go on to Aaron's introduction
I just want to mention again
That you
This whole discussion will be based around your questions
You audience wise
So y'all go ahead and
Text your questions to Karen
Or you can just drop them into the comments
And if you're on Facebook
And we can go ahead and ask them
You can ask them that way
Yeah go ahead and chime in
So Aaron can you share a little bit of
Your kind of story background
Why this is important to you, who you are, all that
Sure I'm Aaron Brown
I grew up in Dallas
My dad is a pastor
So I've been around church life my whole life
He always encouraged me to
Absolutely not become
A pastor although I did
So I took a small trek to medical
School first to become a psychiatrist
And I think that had a lot to do with
Ministry
I got associated with these fine people
From the table through my fiance
Lance
Who has known them for a long time
And absolutely loves them
We would still love to visit more
But we have church at 630
On Sunday nights
I'm the pastor at the Church of Texoma
And you guys are meeting at 5
So we can't make it like we want to
But through the power of media here we are
And so I have
Some personal experience
With anxiety
But more so just my experience working through
And doing therapy and prescribing
And working as a psychiatrist
Awesome
Thank you Aaron
Jacob you want to go ahead and share
Hey yeah
Jacob
So Maggie and I
We live in Plano
But we've lived kind of all over
We first met all these wonderful people
At the table
Back in Wiley
So then we moved off
To Atlanta for a while
And then now we're back
So happy to be back
And
Just me personally I don't know
These topics are important because
I'm a human being and so
We all deal with these things
At different times and various levels
So yeah
Yeah
Go for it Maggie
So I'm Maggie and
We used to go to
Like
Jacob said to
New Hope Locust and so I was very excited
When we moved back to be able to
Connect with y'all again and to
Help y'all launch the table
I personally had never
Struggled with depression
And anxiety until after
I had our son who's about to be
Four
And I
Like just grew up and
Like we never talked about it especially in
Church it was never
Talked about
And so when I started having anxiety
A little bit when I was pregnant but mostly
After I had my son
It was very foreign to me and
Very very upsetting
And then I would say within the last
Couple of years just struggling last
Two years struggling with depression
But
I am definitely
Working through it I think it's a
Work in progress I never think
You do something and you're healed
I think it's a work in progress
Yeah
Cool
Let's go ahead and jump
Into some of our
Questions
So I know
Specifically Karen and Maggie
You kind of touched on this a little bit but
The question
That someone wrote in was for those of you who have
Struggled with anxiety
Or depression
Would you be willing to share
A little bit about your own journey with that
And specifically how
You dealt with it
I think for me
The way
That I deal with it today
Has changed so much
And that's okay
I think whenever
It's something new you don't know
How to react
One of the things that I noticed
For example was that
I really wanted to share
How I felt but there was
A lot of self guilt
On not getting better
Because I kept sharing and sharing
And people
Well many people that love me would
Tell me
Do you know that God loves you
Do you know that He loves me
Do you know that He can heal you
Yes I definitely do know
And those things
I think that I was having trouble
Acknowledging it
And then sharing it as well
Because I had just that self guilt
If I say it
Then I am discrediting
The power of Christ
And so it was just very hard
For me to go through that
Things have changed and of course
When you have a chronic illness
You have a lot of time for yourself
A lot of nights awake
And that has
Actually not been
It has really put me through a journey
From where I was afraid
Where I had this big
Condemnation over my head
Why am I feeling that way
To a place where now I notice that
If I start from a point of view
Where I am acknowledging the feeling
Where I am not trying to run away
Where I am not trying to battle
Where I am not in this
Constant war but I
I know what it feels like
It's like I know it
I acknowledge it's there
And to me once that happens
I can move on
To things that I know
I did try the whole
You read the Bible and it talks about
Bring your thoughts of Christ
Bring everything to the
Obedience of Christ
And it has all these things about action
And I could not
I could barely think
And so I couldn't go into this
Action warfare
I just couldn't do it
So for me the being still
Just the listening
The being present
Was such a big deal
I kept
Reading
Paul talks about
The prophet Paul talks about
Having a thorn
And I have this
Amazing cousin
Who has truly not only supported me
But has single handed me
Just getting me out of that hole
And it talks about
How he three times
Asked for God to remove that thorn
From him and instead he said
My grace is enough
And I think everyone grasps
To a certain thing but my grace is enough
Has been it for me
There's such
Freedom on grace
There's such freedom in the sense that
I can reach out
That I'm not judged
That I am loved
That I am feeling like I'm in a hole today
But that doesn't make me
Less faithful
And so
And one of the things that has also
Really resonated with me is
If I accept
That grace is enough
That grace has
Completely freed me from the judgment
Then I also need to give that to myself
How much
Grace am I giving myself
So I think it is
For me the word
I think everyone has a thing that touches them
But for me in those times
Of complete darkness
It is grace that gets me through it
So that's my particular
Way that I
Has really morphed
From a place of full condemnation
To a place of where I can
Accept and be open to grace
Yeah I can
Definitely feel
And agree with that
I have also felt
Like shame for
Having anxiety or depression
Like you know why am I not enough
To not have these things
And I want
To answer Norma's question
What is the best way for those of us
Who struggle with anxiety or depression
To walk alongside
Love, support someone who does
Just being there
I feel like the past few years
Jacob and my
Close family and friends
Have just been
You know not even like
Said a whole lot
But just the fact that like
Him and them
Have just been there
When I have been upset or down
You know not necessarily
Um
Saying like you know
Oh everything's going to be okay like
Oh you should read your bible more
Like nothing like that but just like
It's okay to feel your feelings
And this too shall pass
Um
Especially when I have had
Like panic attacks
Um just you know hugging me
And um
Just helping me count
And breathe while that passes
Um and then if I have
Had like bouts of depression then you know
Just to
Like Jacob will just remind me that like
It's okay like that this is not going to last
Forever and there's nothing
Wrong with me
Wow
That's um that's powerfully put
Thank you Maggie and Karen
Um
Yeah any any other
Uh thoughts on that either
Uh Aaron or Jacob or anyone else
Before we keep keep moving
Thank goodness
I don't like uh one thought that I
Had was um as far as
Like being um supporting
Someone who's dealing with this stuff
Um I know that I definitely
So
When we're talking about like
Stress anxiety and depression
Like those three words I think kind of
Get uh tossed around a lot
Um and
It's not to diminish
Anyone's experience
Because we all deal with
You know stress and anxiety and
Uh sadness um but
There's even another level
Of it right that's like um
I don't know clinical um
To where it's like it's
Real it's uh it's a whole nother
Experience and um one
Huge thing um that
I think really helps our
Relationship when um
You started dealing with a lot of this stuff was
Like uh one of the
Reasons that we moved back um
Was that I was working in Atlanta
And we were I was commuting
Um basically
At least two hours
A day in the car
And uh over
The you know two years of
Doing that um I started
Developing like actual
Physical panic attacks as well like in the
Car and then it was like
This is this is what this is
Because Maggie has been talking about this stuff
Um and I never knew
What she was talking about um so
It's uh
It's like it's really real
So like when if someone that
You love is like talking about dealing
With anxiety um and like panic
Attacks specifically um
It's a very scary feeling uh
Like you feel like you're going to
Die right it's um
And it's not really logical
And um so there isn't
Really a whole lot to
Um
I don't know do about it except like
Maggie said like just be there and like
Reassurance and like that kind
Of thing so um
One thing that I would just say
I guess all that wrapped up
Is that like give yourself
A little grace and um
You know realize that
Like these things that we're dealing with are
Powerful and they're
Difficult and there's not really a lot of
Answers right so
We're all figuring it out
Yeah there's that
Word grace again and
Uh yeah that's a
Seems like a big deal
Um
Aaron did you have something
I mean I think they're all talking about
What people tend to feel which is
Just kind of this shame for
Being weak or for having mental
Illness it's really common
Um working at a nursing home now it's
Hilarious because I walk in the room and I go
Have you ever had depression or anxiety and they're like
No no never like because there's just a shame
Associated with it and I look at the
Med list and there's like
Prozac, Zoloft
It's like oh they've had problems with depression
And anxiety um but
We compound it by
Adding the shame onto it um
So I think all three of y'all have said
It like once you learn to be okay with what you
Feel it didn't make
All of anxiety and depression go away but
Like you at least didn't have this compounded
Emotion of shame on top
Yep yep
Um
Something Raymond kind of just chimed in with
Um a little bit ago in the comments was
Could Aaron talk about like therapy and medication
Um and
I'm I'm kind of
Assuming he's he's speaking to
Maybe the question of you know at
What point should someone pursue
That or you know what's
Run of the mill anxiety
Or depression that'll kind of you know
Maybe take care of itself over time
Versus something more like
Oh that's no that's something you need
You know to to seek professional help over
What do you have any input
Um there
Yeah I'd say at the point that you want to
Um at the point that it
Bothers you enough at the point where you're not
Happy with the way that you're living that's the
Point where you start seeking help
Um so that's going to be at different places
For different people
Just like it is physically when a person
Hurts their arm and they
Don't even think to go to the doctor and the next person
Does um it's the same with mental
Illness at the point where it disturbs you
It hurts your relationships
It hurts you at work or you just don't
Feel as happy with your life as you want to
That's the point at which you get help
Yeah yeah that's
That's great
Uh this has been kind of alluded to a
Little bit but I wondered if if you
All um I think it was really Karen who
Gave a little bit of an example of how
The church kind of factored into
Her experience um I was
Wondering um maybe
If y'all could speak a little bit to that
Like how have you seen
The church um
Kind of
I guess interact with either you or
Others kind of you know who are struggling with like
Mental illness and then you know and that
Could be good or bad but what what's what's
Been your experience um
And yeah unpack that way we can maybe
Get into how should the church
Do better potentially I'm
Presuming all your stories won't be it was
Perfection oh my gosh everyone just you know
Um so anyway yeah
Could you could you speak to that kind of first
Part um anyone that wants to chime in
I think for
Me there's a the stigma
And the fear that
Comes from the acknowledgement of mental
Health is very
Palpable um in the
Christian part
Of things or at least that was my experience
Uh one of the things that I like about
Talking um today
Is that it takes away the
Stigma and it just that conversation
Helps you get away from
That but for me
I know that for my mom it hurt her
Heart when I try to talk about
Depression because she
Started getting calling my pastor
Elders I mean
Because she just tried to just
Get me out of that hole
And and so so then
They call me and they prayed and I
Love that but then I feel pressure
Next time when they're like how you doing and I have to say
Um I'm better because
Otherwise if I don't do that
I am not it's like
If I'm broken then it
Means that crisis is broken
And so there's this thing that you can't really
Acknowledge it um that's good
And so that you know that that example
That we have to the world
And that
Fulfillness of life and I wasn't representing
That so for me it was really
Hard to acknowledge that part
And I started thinking about how
This I have this really good
Support group uh for
Eight women and none
Of them are
Christian and so to me
I kept going back to that I'm like why am
I getting so much support from them
And one of the things I
Noticed that I was getting from them that I
Wasn't getting from my
Christian community was that
They acknowledge how I felt
Um they gave
It a name it wasn't something you run or it
Wasn't something you just pray away
Either um it was something
That yes prayer supports um
Companionship support is there
But one thing that I love was that
They to this day ask
Me how can I support you
And my husband for example goes
Into problem solving mode
Fix it fix it fix it fix it
And I'm you know
I understand what he wants to do but
That's not what I need
Um so I was Maggie
Was talking about you know
She needs to be held I need to be
Left alone do not touch me
Do not talk to me it's very
Big so just finding
That support someone that can listen
To you that can acknowledge you that
Doesn't see you
For the church that doesn't see my
Brokenness as a
Reflection that I don't have enough
Faith or that I don't
Or that Christ is broken and
It truly isn't um the
Whole idea of how has my faith playing in
There like do you have enough faith
Have it is my faith
That has sustained you that has kept
Me here like I
Don't know where I would be without
I don't know if I would be here today without
That faith and the
Bible does not deny my faith
And that is a huge thing
Um that I struggle with
Uh with just the whole
Experience that I've had with church
Yeah Karen
I think the irony is like our main symbol
As Christians is a cross
But we struggle with the idea of
Suffering
It shouldn't be
Like I always have to present
Uh this wonderful picture to the world
Because that's how I represent Christ
Like Christ came in
Suffering for us
So sometimes even our suffering is
A true identification with
Christ like not the opposite
Beautifully put
Anyone else want to chime in on that
Or on anything that was said
Karen what Karen said
I got questions
So I'll keep going
Alright so the Bible
It speaks about having like joy
And peace
Because we have a relationship with God
But what do you do when you
Don't have that joy and peace
In your heart
Is that a sign of
Like there's a number of questions here
So A what do you do when you don't have joy and peace
In your heart is that a sign of some sort of
Unfaithfulness to God
Why do others seem to have a joy
When I don't
Again you know
Is this something to do with me
So kind of the two there's a lot going on there
But I can hear the you know
What do I do when I like I'm reading the Bible
But I don't seem to have that joy and peace in my heart
Um
You know is that a sign of some sort of
Wrongness in me or unfaithfulness to God
Uh yeah could y'all speak to that
Oh I enjoy this one
I just did a sermon on it
We were actually talking about sin
And I talked about how multifaceted
It is and it's the same with this like
Um we are born with different
Temperaments
Um we're born with different biological factors
Um like we found out that
A lot of a higher
Population of people in prison have an
Extra wide chromosome it tends to make them
More aggressive and things like that
Um so sometimes you're
Feeling aggressive angry and
Their genetic biological
Temperamental factors that
All play in and it has
Nothing to do with your relationship
With God um
And then I would say at the same time I think
There are a lot of things we can do that
Are still helpful um like I've
Seen you do a sermon on spiritual
Disciplines and there
Are all sorts of things that help us
Become more aware of the
Presence of God um I would
Say that you're never out of God's presence
In the psalms it talks about
Even if I feel he's there
Um it's not like I can escape the presence
Of God so you haven't done anything to make
God go away because God is so big that there's no
Place for us for him to go
Um but
There are things that keep us from being fully aware
Of God's presence and spiritual
Disciplines and all those other things help
Um but we can't ignore
All the other biological
And temperamental factors
And make it just spiritual
Yeah I was gonna say
Um like I know that was a
Hypothetical question but if someone was
Really asking that it's like why don't
You put down the bible and like
Go do something that you want to do
Right like um
Like listen to your body
Like we're
Uh
I don't know like one of the biggest things that
Um has especially like
The past couple months like getting through all this
Um you know
Social distancing and like
Staying in the house all day
Um is like finding some hobbies
Um and
Uh I don't know it really helps me
Maggie's not quite as much of a hobby
Person um but like
For me
Uh
But for like for me it's like okay
Well um you know sitting
Around and praying and
You know meditating all day
Like that's not going to fulfill me
Um and so
I don't think there's anything wrong with
Uh your whole day
Not being centered around spirituality
Like experience things like find
Pleasure like that's one of the huge things
That I have a problem with
Um
Some of the way that church
Typically is um
Like I don't know
Practiced or taught the teachings
Um and the
Church at least in this country
Is um
Like denial of self
And um you know purity culture
And everything that's wrapped up
In that um and it's like
I don't know there's nothing wrong with
Experiencing things as
A human being and uh
Finding pleasure in life so
Um I don't know
Yeah yeah thank you
Anyone else before we
Keep on moving
Okay
Um
So uh Norma
Chimed in asking is there ever a situation
Where you could be like enabling
Someone in their stress
Anxiety depression um
And so what does it look like to
Help but also be
Uh I'm kind of thinking maybe
Norma you can chime in the comments
If I'm kind of misreading this but
Uh like maybe
Where someone's sinking into
Kind of like an isolation or something
And uh and you
Um
You want to
Maybe help but you don't
But without um
Perpetuate it like maybe
In essence um
Someone's kind of going into a bad place
But you know you don't want to be pushy or anything
Or you don't want to be unhelpful
So you just kind of let them
Go into a bad place
But you're like ah how do I
Walk this line maybe where I don't want to be pushy
But I think there might be you know
Something extreme like what if they hurt themselves or what you know
Whatever um anyway I think that might
Be the question behind the question
Uh you can okay she says yes so
I'll go with yeah so anyway um
Yeah any thoughts on on some of that
Like how yeah what if someone's in that place
I want to set
Karen up because I thought she answered
It earlier like
She said she went to a group and
They asked her what do you need
Like they didn't make assumptions about what she needed
Like they just asked her um
And then Maggie I see you nodding
Like was that your experience too
Um
A little bit
I think it was a lot
Of you know
Jacob and Anika spoke together all the time
Um being
A little too much together
These days um
Being like
You know him just kind of being
Open
Like nobody being defensive you know
Like if you are
Someone who doesn't deal with it
And then someone you have someone
In your life who does and then being
Like this is how I feel
You know like Jacob is never like well
You shouldn't feel like that like you know
Why are you feeling like that you know
You have such a great life um
But just being like oh you know that's how she
Felt like that right now um
I feel like what can I do for you
Um
That group sounds really awesome
Um just you know how
I mean how can I pray
For you um like
Do you want me to send you
Funny quotes
Every day like you know
Do you want us to talk a few times
A week on the phone just about life
Do you want us to not talk about it at all
While you process it
Um
I think just but not denying
Like not ignoring
Their pain um
And their anxiety and depression
Not being like not acting like
That it's not true
Because it is very true
Yeah
I think just to add to that
For me and this is an I
Statement
My personal opinion my experience has been
That I have
This cousin who is like a sister
To me and I don't know how this woman
Hasn't gotten tired of checking
Up on me because there are
Signs I got anxiety talking
On the phone and so
She calls me and she knows that there are days that I
Can't talk and I'll text her
But just a constant check
In making sure you're okay she doesn't tell me
What to do um she calls
Me and tells me how you're doing hey
She's gonna tell me hey I'm just calling to remind
You you are the righteousness of God
That you are the chosen one you're holy
I mean this woman just
Tells me just reminds me
Of things that sometimes my head is
Telling me otherwise it's just a voice
Um
And and I do feel
That at some point we go
Through this grieving process and
It's hard sometimes to
Look for help or how we can voice
Help but I do personally
Feel like there is a point where it becomes
Um a personal choice how
We are going to seek help
Um that we do have autonomy
On that and that
For me to realize
That I needed to
Go seek that help I mean that's something
That my husband could not have made me do
It had to do with me
Searching for it it was
Affecting not only
My job like we talk about
The brain fog um but it
Also affected my relationship
With my own child I have an only daughter
And my ability to be
Present so at that point
It does become more than
Um support but also
Encouragement to look
For help to what have
You done did this therapy work
And I don't have any
Um stigma
On saying you know I had to
Search for therapy and I had to search
For meds and I had to
Have this thing that would move me forward
So I think a lot of times
We worry that
That we are
Not helping our loved ones who have anxiety
And that we are
Indulging them in their anxiety
And while I completely think that's a
That's how many people will feel
I think that checking up on them
Being that that person doesn't give up
On them or just that resonating
Um message of who
They are helps but I do think that
At some point it is
It is up to the person who is going
Through this to seek
To seek help and find out
What can I do
But that's my opinion again my
I statement
Well put
Any follow ups there from anyone
Before I keep moving
Okay
Um so this um
Next one it says I hear
A lot of isolation
Causes stress and anxiety
Um which can lead to depression
Which then cycles back to
Increased isolation
What are some
Healthy ways
I can cope with this cycle
So it sounds like someone who
Kind of finds themselves isolating
Experiencing anxiety and depression which kind of
Makes them distance more
Which then you know it's this kind of
Vicious circle
Any
Part of it it is a cycle
The whole anxiety I mean it is one
Of those things that
You feel bad because you're not
Interacting with your friends you feel like you
Are being a bad friend a bad mom a bad
And then that just makes things worse and
You go all around and it just
Seems like you can't get out of it
Um isolation is a big
Part and we're living it right now
And it's
Really to me it's just very
In my face that I
Support that I would usually find
I take a lot of joy
In my job
And interacting with my co-workers
And then our first school district so
Interacting with my students and that's not there
And that has been
Such a huge empty spot for
Me um so I've had to
Connect in other ways um
Online thank goodness we have that
Um honestly
The text that I get from
Pastor Brett for any type of
Connection to me means so
Much more now um
We've done
Happy hours with my friends
Online where we can just sit there and
Talk um
Connecting with people
In for example I have a online
Community for people with RA
Um that helps out a lot as well
Finding just support
Uh people around you don't
Be afraid to reach out
I think you would be amazed
Of how many people
Are going through the same thing you're going
Or feeling isolated and I think we tend
To think it's only us
And then you talk to people and they're
Like oh yeah I didn't know people
Who had anxiety when talking on the
Phone that was like new to me and they're like
Oh yeah I avoid phone calls
You know but I think
That's the beautiful thing of reaching
Out um
And just getting past that point
Where you're just so consumed
By the loneliness
And by the isolation when this thing
Came out and they were going over
Who is more vulnerable and they're talking about
Immunosuppressed
Asthma
Then they say obesity
And I'm like listen
We're not gonna go through this but
It became this big thing
Am I gonna die? It just became really
Real and I went into that
Portion it was just dark and
For sure this is what's gonna kill me
So for me to find support
To talk it out to find someone that was
You know well listen to you if you're
If you're afraid
We're gonna validate you
That to me also had to do with
Finding again
That support group I feel like the support
Idea it's mentioned and people hear
It a lot but it truly
Is or at least for me is what
Gets me through this isolation which can be
Very dark
Yeah
I would say I've definitely felt
More
It's gotten better the last couple of weeks
But just the past like eight or nine weeks
Of quarantine
The first week, week and a half was pretty
Okay but I felt like I was
Starting to be
Really down for a few weeks and was
Really depressed I think a lot of it
Was mom guilt
From
You know Sam being home all the time
But then I now as opposed
To when he was going to preschool
And then having
The cycle of well I
Feel depressed so I don't feel
Like you know I don't feel
Totally present I don't feel like I can just
Enjoy him and play with him all day
And I feel guilty about that
And so I but I've been trying
To really just if
The mom guilt thoughts come in just
To let them go
And I would say the last
Two weeks I've done
Really well
About that about
Just kind of
Letting it go and be like I have a great kid
I'm a great mom I'm pretty bad about
Speaking like positive thoughts
To myself because I'm
Not that
I think I'm terrible but
It's easier to speak
Things to other people
Like to tell you know
Jacob and Sam they're so great and amazing
Than it is to tell myself
So I think that cycle
Is not very helpful but I'm
Trying to
To get out of that
Negative cycle
Yeah
And I think a quick technique that helps with that
Is finding one person who you really trust
While you're feeling good
And you give
Them permission to be the one to tell you
If you need to get back out
Because we all do kind of need our alone time
And those things and it's hard to judge
When you've crossed the line
From that
And just pure
Isolation that's going to lead to more depression
It's really hard to tell when you're in the middle
Of it and so while you're feeling good you tell
That one person I will trust you and if you say
I've been at home too much or I'm not getting
Enough social contact then we will do
Something about it on the spot
But just give one person the trust
And that's speaking to your life in that way
That's a great
Handle because I think
It's something I've heard as you all have been talking
Is on the one hand
You know having a bunch of people
Kind of come at us like hey you're not
Doing this well and you're not
Really helpful
But on the other hand
Like we can get in that isolated
Place and so it's like
I love that that's a great insight of
Okay give that who's that one person
You trust that knows you well and that knows
How to do it in a sensitive loving way
But who can be honest
With you too that's really well put
And
Kind of our time
Is starting to come to a close
But one of the
Key kind of
Takeaways well two takeaways
I've heard from this or I'm taking
Kind of from this conversation is
In terms of how we can help how we can be there
For others who are in
Experiencing these kind of intense
Challenging emotions is
The
Idea of asking the question
How can I be there
What do you need what would you like from me
I thought that's really helpful
And as well as
Something
Karen I think mentioned this
Although so did Maggie in a way when she was describing
Jacob and their relational dynamic
Is the idea of presence of
Just being there for
Someone
I wondered kind of in closing
How if it's
Either emphasizing those or other ways
Like how can
We as the church as folks
In community with others
How can we do better on this
You know moving forward
What can we change
Yeah
How can we do better
Okay here's my kind of controversial
Take
I think actually
Where the church has had problems is we've
Overstepped
Like we haven't been trained in mental illness we haven't been
Trained in anxiety
So I think we're trying to take what we learned about
Spirituality and we're
Applying it too broadly
So in Matthew 6 where Jesus talks about
Not being anxious I guarantee
You he did not have generalized anxiety disorder
Or PTSD in mind
But we've taken
That passage and applied it
Broadly to things that weren't even happening
In Jesus' day
So I think one of the best things we can do as a church
Is stick to what we know
Like help people spiritually
And there's a spiritual component to mental illness
That I think the church can be very helpful with
Most psychiatrists
And therapists are going to ask about your spirituality
During a session because it is a part
But we have people who are
Trained in dealing with the biological part
And the psychological part
Just like we would do with cancer
We should probably just say I love you
I'll pray for you what do you need
But here are the people who can help
Then I think the church can also be
Very beneficial in dealing with shame
I think depression
And anxiety both have
A huge basis in
Feelings of shame
And for people who grew up in church
So much of their experience was shame based
And fear based
And so again that spiritual component of it
Is one of the things that the church could address
Like how do we go back
And teach the gospel
In a way that's about God's unconditional love
And God's total presence
With you and not your total
Depravity and how terrible you are
Which of course is shame based
So how can the church
Change that rhetoric in a way that we show people
That they're already loved by God
And loved infinitely and unconditionally
I think that would at least help
With the spiritual component of anxiety
And so again
We need to be there
And we need to refer to people who can help
Yeah, yeah
Thank you
Karen, Maggie or Jacob
Have any final thoughts on this topic
This question of how the church can do better
I think just talking about it
Like the fact that we're here
Talking about it, acknowledging it
That's in my experience
Something that I have not experienced
Through church before
It's not that you're having a bad day
Like Aaron mentioned
It's something that is pervasive
And will have an impact on you
And to acknowledge that just as you would
Another type of sickness or disease
And I feel like that helps out a lot
In talking about it brings awareness
It also brings to where
I don't feel like I'm the only one
I don't feel like I'm odd either
So to me
That is the biggest thing
Let's start with talking about it
That it affects a lot of people
And that it affects people different ways
I think small groups
Any of that kind of stuff
That we would have to
I keep talking about support groups
But I also understand that I'm in a very privileged position
To say my family does this
My friends do this
And not everyone would have that big advantage
And so I think that's where church could come in
With providing that support
If that person feels welcome
And accepted
By that group
Yeah
Yeah I was going to say
Just the fact that
We're even opening up this
Conversation
I think that
I thought that was great
When I read your email
I was like that is very good
I think it gives people
Or like when I hear about other people
Deal with depression
Anxiety
It
It almost like I'm like
Thank God I'm not the only one
Even I know there are so many
Of us who struggle with it
It's still
It's just like a breath of fresh air
Just to remember that you're not alone
Yeah
One of the biggest things for me
Pretty much the only thing for me
Right now is the
Church
Provides this community
And so that's to me that's one of the
Biggest things that we
Keep touching on is
Needing relationship
Because like
We're not meant to be
Doing this thing
By ourselves right
And whether that's
You know just one or two
Relationships or many relationships
The church
Is kind of one of those common ground
Places that we should be able to come to
And have a safe space
And unfortunately it hasn't always been that way but
Like Aaron was saying
Just have to stop
Pushing the shame
And start teaching
People about their inherent
Worth and their goodness
And hopefully
We can start rewriting some of that
So
And when Karen just commented
Karen Miner just said church is not a substitute
For professional therapy
I like my voice
Yes
Yeah and anyone who's
Done any counseling with me knows I
Will meet with you twice and then
Make a referral
So
Well done
Yes and yeah
Well thank you
Karen and Aaron Maggie Jacob
I'm so grateful thank you for like opening up
Your own lives and heart and
Aaron I know you have like church stuff
Today and you know other things going on
So thank you for
Just taking the time to love on our community
And share
I'm really really grateful
So if we were all like together
Everyone would say give them a round of applause
Come on everybody and everyone would like stand to their feet
They're like oh my gosh it was amazing
We're online though so
It's a little quiet but I know
They're saying like they'll probably leave comments and things
Like they'll say like we love you so
Anyway thank y'all so much
I'm going to go ahead and pray
And then we're going to have a closing
Song so
Panelists if you want you can stay
On for my prayer but you can also just leave
So either way is fine so
I love y'all thank you
Thank you
Lord Jesus we
Just thank you for
This time and this conversation
God I pray that it's open to eyes
And hearts and minds
And whatever truth
Was spoken
God and
Was
Really heard by someone I pray it would go deep
God deep into their
Heart and mind
And that they would find the
Support the love the insight
The courage
That they need
The healing that they need
And may the table may we be a church
Community that loves well
And we know we won't get it perfect but
Help us to love well
Lord so we give you this
This night this time this conversation
Name of Christ I pray
Amen
Yeah thanks guys
And just want to add
My little two cents
I struggle with this too you know
And so
One thing I find very helpful is just
Choose to smile
One way I heard it was a it's like an advanced
Yoga move you move up the corners of your
Mouth
And you do that enough it will
Make you feel better
But you have to choose to do it
So yeah happy Mother's Day
And I'm gonna sing
The song called the way you are
It's by a friend of ours
His name is Jonathan
Ruel
And so yeah just enjoy
You're bright
Like silver
Flashing light on
Waves
You make me
Gasp
Your virtue makes me wait
I cannot
Grasp
The paths you indicate
I only
Ask
You keep me in the way
The way
You are
Tomorrow and today
The way
Your heart
Courageously forgets
When I miss
That part
You can make me live
Your humble
Words
Break through these haughty sneers
Your gentle
Touch
Removes these thorn like fears
Your eyes
Burn bright
Into my darkness caught
You ask me
Out
You brought me to the way
The way
You are
Tomorrow and today
The way
Your heart
Courageously forgets
When I miss
That part
You can make me live
Da da da da
You brought me to the way
The way
You are
Tomorrow and today
The way
Your heart
Courageously forgets
When I miss
That part
You can make me live
The way
Your heart
Courageously forgets
When I miss
That part
You can make me live
Your humble
considerately
Brothers and sisters
You are God's servants
You're gifted with dreams
You're gifted with visions
And upon you rests the grace of God like flames of fire
Go
Love
Serve the Lord in the strength of the Holy Spirit
Love you all, have a great week
you